un chien fidèle pour une électricité
et cette loyauté devrait encore une fois
s'exprimer le 3 octobre
parmi ces principales préoccupations
l'accès à des services en anglais
[Musique]
votera aussi encore une fois pour les
libéraux mais sans grand enthousiasme
ça montre encore que le Parti libéral ne
peut plus est fragiliser pour ce
spécialiste des enjeux linguistiques
cette élection sera marquée par
l'éclatement du vote anglophone on
aurait peut-être serré les rangs si on
sentait qu'il y avait la possibilité
d'une d'une majorité libérale
l'affaiblissement du Parti libéral
permet donc à une communauté minoritaire
de
d'avoir des options
le Parti conservateur ne sait d'ailleurs
pas gêné pour courtiser ouvertement les
anglophones les lits nous avons
abandonné ça fait longtemps un appel
entendu par cette ancienne électeur
libéral qui compte appuyer régulièrement
je pense qu'il est un bon gars à part
qui doit l'argent au gouvernement il est
pas fait des formations plus marginales
tendent aussi la main aux anglophones
comme le parti canadien ou le bloc
Montréal de balaramaro NES qui devrait
le vote de cette électrice parce que je
crois que à Montréal on a besoin de ces
différentes
représentatifs ça nous donne plus de
choix cette représentante de la
communauté anglophone se réjouit ce
nouveau paysage politique qui croit-elle
sert bien la démocratie
très diverses et nous ne sommes pas
homogène non plus on a des
préoccupations différentes pour le
prouver suffit de demander l'enjeu
prioritaire des citoyens rencontrés
la santé le changement climatique
mais ce qui rallie bon nombre
d'anglophones c'est l'opposition à la
loi 96 du gouvernement Legault qui
réforme la Charte de la langue française
par exemple une certificat de mariage
maintenant doit être uniquement en
français c'était aussi il y a des choses
qui qui ont l'air un peu mais c'est pas
nécessaire pour promouvoir le français
ou peut toucher le français
je trouve que la loi est un peu hard of
touch avec la réalité cette électricité
Québec solidaire qui a voté en faveur la
nouvelle loi
politique mais il y en a pas qui sont
complètement alignés avec mes valeurs
mais quand même faut quand même voter
c'est assez important
visiblement cette fois bien les
anglophones voteront avec résignation
ici Mathieu papillon Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]